the Wright loves to talk about you know
Chicago and Baltimore as these
crime-ridden hell holes the truth is
that even within cities that have gun
violence problems the gun violence is
overwhelmingly concentrated in a few
areas most of Chicago most of New York
City most of Baltimore does not actually
have these issues this is aside from
whether
the issues relate to a particular
politics or how it relates to the state
or whatever the case may be and as I've
said before
let's talk about mental health let's
talk about culture let's talk about
poverty let's talk about education let's
talk about all those things but we can't
exclude guns from the gun problem guns
have to be part of that discussion